I'm gonna be 60 years old jalan Tom  Hanks gets candid about his big birthday  milestone the actor turned 60 this July  but he's not exactly planning a blow out  birthday bash in fact he told ET on  Wednesday he's gonna keep his  celebration simple and just enjoy a  frosty beverage I grew up having my  birthday's in the in the summer time  where everybody is dispersed so I have a  feeling that the day will go by with  just a little bit of an odd enough and  maybe a delightfully cold can of beer in  order to celebrate the big six show but  you know maybe a surprise party hbu you  never know I mean you have anyways I'm  gonna kill somebody but there is one  person who might get a pass Oprah the  hologram for the Kings star gushed he's  always down to hang with lady OH usually  if Oprah calls and says you want to hang  who turns down that opportunity